did you ever I heard this could be a
joke but did you ride into Playboy for
advice like career advice and what kind
of career opportunity was one looking
for riding into
Playboy I was a desperate young guy okay
yeah I didn't know what to do with my
musical life and so I saw this thing in
Playboy Magazine my stepfather I guess
used to buy it and I sent you just outed
him I like it yeah right so I sent a
letter saying I have an offer to go on
the road with uh with a girl singer I
play piano uh and in order to do that I
had to leave my job at CBS as the
mailboy which is steady work which one
should I do yeah and they they wrote me
back and they printed it and they said
take the job outside and follow your
musical notes oh I love that and I did I
left you left and you did it I left CBS
so really you have Playboy to thank for
everything I do so I know that you and
bet were together um quite a bit so and
I did she help you promote your first
album well yes she let me uh I was her
music director and conductor and
arranger and um we went on the road
together and I had this first album and
I didn't want to leave her and so what
she was very generous she let me open
her second act so instead of her coming
out yeah the piano player came out and
you know you know that was crazy the
audience didn't want to see the piano
player singing three songs I know that
but again they were very kind best
audiences were very kind to me and they
let me do three songs uh and it was the
beginning of my performing career wow I
think you're wrong though I do think
audiences love I have um my band do that
sometimes like come in and out I think
they do love seeing artists support
other artists I think that's a big a big
thing well she was great to let me do
that and then you then then I actually
did take off on my own and uh yeah and
here I am I know and then she then she
was like crap I shouldn't have let him
sing I lost my musical director like
you're right that's amazing so wait
never forgave me but you I love it she's
like where the hell did you go
[Music]
[Applause]
like thank you guys y'all have a great
night guys I'm going
home